it all started with a phone call in july
president donald trump spoke to the
newly elected president of ukraine
vladimir zelinski we had a perfect phone
call with the president of ukraine
but the transcript of that phone call
reveals that mr trump
put pressure on mr zielenski to
investigate hunter biden
and his father joe biden the potential
democratic nominee
for the 2020 presidential election the
gist of the accusation from democrats
against donald trump
is that he's essentially both abused his
office and betrayed the national
interest
by putting pressure on ukraine's
president
to investigate a political rival and
that president trump
withheld military aid vital military aid
for an american ally
until the president of ukraine did what
he wanted
the democrats are hoping the current
impeachment proceedings will help to
reduce support for donald trump
but could they do the opposite
committee will come to order good
morning everyone
right now hearings are being held in the
house of representatives
where the democrats have a majority it
seems fairly clear that the house will
vote to
impeach president trump at that point
the trial will move to the senate
in order to remove a president in a
senate trial you need a two-thirds
majority so you'd have to get all the
democrats plus about
20 republicans if you get into the
polling on
impeachment and removal republicans do
not want donald trump impeached
or removed so it's very hard to see
lots of senators lots of republican
senators
voting to convict him when their own
voters are so strongly supportive of the
president
so that's to say nothing of the you know
merits of the charges or the evidence
against him in pure political polling
terms
it looks really unlikely that you get
enough republican senators to move on
this
and history is also on president trump's
side
of the three previous presidents who
have faced impeachment none have been
removed by the senate
andrew johnson was impeached and was one
vote away
from being removed from office
i shall resign the presidency effective
at noon tomorrow
after the watergate scandal richard
nixon resigned before he could be
impeached
i did not have sexual relations with
that woman
bill clinton was impeached but was saved
in the senate
and in the midterm elections during the
proceedings his party in fact
gained seats president
trump's support base is likely to remain
stable whatever questions are raised
about his conduct as a result of the
impeachment hearings
polling suggests that the more partisan
the hearings appear
the more likely voters are to behave the
same way and back their own team
the polling now on impeachment breaks
down pretty much
the same way that approval of donald
trump breaks down so those two things
have come into line
donald trump is not a hugely popular
president but that said he does have a
sort of bedrock of about 40 percent
support that's about the same chair who
are opposed to impeachment
for the most part mr trump's supporters
have stood by him
trump's net approval was at its highest
at his inauguration
by the start of 2018 it had fallen by
around 12 points
since then it's remained relatively
steady
apart from a dip in support during the
government shutdown earlier this year
since the impeachment proceeding started
his approval ratings have barely
faltered
but could impeachment actually increase
support for mr trump
if you talk to people at the white house
what they will say is oh all this
impeachment talk is good for us you know
that it'll help
president trump in the polls they're
saying actually it'll be an electoral
boost to us
i'm not sure about that i'm also not
convinced that it helps democrats
a huge amount if you go back about a
month the house leadership was still
concerned that impeachment might really
backfire for democrats
that if you're a democrat running in a
marginal seat or a district where
donald trump did well that actually
would hurt the democrats chances of
re-election
the majority of voters in key swing
states oppose
president trump's removal so impeachment
might not harm him in the way democrats
would like
they have long believed that mr trump
should pay a price for his norm breaking
behavior
but given that voting to impeach him is
a risky decision for democrats
why have they chosen to do it now a lot
of democrats went to the speaker and
said listen if we don't impeach the
president
for this what what do we impeach him for
and there was a sense that they'd be
giving him a free pass for all sorts of
behavior i'm announcing the house of
representatives moving forward
with an official impeachment inquiry i
think democrats
genuinely believe that what he did in
his phone call with
president zielinski was very bad and i
think privately there are quite a few
republicans who agree with him on that
you